Oh
Okay
I don't recognize you anymore
more
la la la
la la la la
la
eh
ah
my my check what you what you what you
well, all right, that's that's
I was I thought I was mute
I thought I was muted. I usually mute this before I start
But I didn't I didn't mute this. I didn't mute anything
I can't even hear my own bgm
I
Can you guys hear the bgm? Is this just me?
You can hear it what?
Oh my god, I muted the wrong thing
I thought I muted my mic instead. I muted the bgm for myself
ah
I'm sorry. I'm so sorry
I already remember what I was gonna say anymore. I don't remember
Hi, everyone. Hi. Hi my little pleating heart. How is everyone doing today?
Hi
Hi, welcome in to today's stream
We're gonna play we're gonna be playing some some story to the valley starting up the valley
Ohio
Is it it's it's a good is it morning for you?
Oh my god
Oh
But another year
I'm just like saying Ohio. It's okay. I understand. It's a fun word. Ohio
It's a good it's a good evening for me
Oh, you just woke up
Morning
It's a fun word my chat has frozen my chat has frozen
Uh-oh, there he goes
Yeah
It's 8 p.m. For me it's also 8 p.m. For me it's 8 p.m
8 o 9 now
Up there very happy Sunday
I hope I wasn't singing too loud. I had that song on repeat before starting
It's known there
My job
By my merch by by by my merch
My merch and ties
Me
I didn't have a I don't have a very I don't I didn't have a very productive productive morning
I woke up with
A horrendous headache and then I was really hot and sweaty
And I was up. I try to go back to sleep. I just couldn't go back to sleep. It was impossible
Hey
Oh, I wouldn't call it productive
Every time someone says sniff a sniff off right for some reason
Then my nose does the scrunch thingy. It just scrunches
And I can't
Is that not is that like just like
It's like just my body just reacting to that word
Every time I read it
I'm just urged to this sniff
Is me moving my nose
I
Am I'm ready to get straight into some stardom my head
Feels like poo poo
My head feels like poo poo
I have to be honest my head is poo poo. Oh, oh poo poo
What song was that
Black out no black out days. I think I think I think
Yeah
Oh, sorry big shirt. Sorry
I
Oh, I didn't I never set up this game
Oh
Yeah, I'm so professional today
Can you believe it? Oh my god
Um
Oh, there it is
I was so ready for this
Get blinded get blinded get blinded get blinded
Flashbang
Get blinded
I'm proud of my biggest pro ever so professional
Uh
So
Star
This game is so loud. Why is it so loud? Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
I'll fix I'll fix I'll make game that loud. What is this?
I
Yes, that's the name of this that's where the song is from black black black out
Uh, not blacked out but black out black out days by those uh ventogram. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Is this gonna be a new save or one of yours a new save we're gonna start from the beginning
We're gonna start from the very very beginning like where it started with me when I first brought humanity
Uh
To life whoa
We're gonna start from the beginning
Where am I?
No, I'm not sleepy. No, I don't know where the yarn came from
It just hit me all of a sudden, but I'm not sleepy trust trust trust
Don't be fooled the body can trick you. I am not sleepy. Don't be fooled. Whoa
Not sleepy
Not sleepy. I swear not sleepy
I'm not sleepy
Just just just for that just for that. I'm gonna grab a red bull now. I'm grabbing a red bull
Grabbing the red bull
Okay, I got it got a rebel now bam we drinking a rebel
Rebel
It gives you wings I could already float I could levitate a hundred new wings
Oh my god, I stuck a fly
How to open open
I
Yeah
Woo-hoo
I did it
I know some of the Easter eggs in the title screen wasn't there something where you click on something
Or you could click the other leaves
And then the June the most pop up and then there was one where um
You're not gonna eat
And your alien is there any and say hello. Um, I don't know about the other one. Oh
Oh
And you put it in here
Haha, look at that. Why?
I think I played too much dirty valley
I
How many hours does mama have in stardew, uh
Um
Two two thousand hours no more more definitely more
More
Fourth fourth no six thousand hours. No, no less more. I don't know
No
Hmm
What flavor rebel I can't have sugar so um
And rebel has like a lot of sugar in it. So I have to get zero sugar
Um
There was sugar
I got sugar-free rebel no flavor. I don't think they sell flavors over here
Hmm
I
I got a lot hours in stardew. I play quite a bit
Quite a bit
Um a stardew for a while
A bit
Me
Is this loud for anyone else or is it just me cause this is loud.
is that I was the only one is that better for you guys I have to turn it down for
myself only when it was freaking loud for me I had it on 50
turn it down a little more whoa I'm a turn it down a little more I am me hi
and me hi and me hi everyone welcome in from a mainstream how did you guys
enjoy a mainstream what you and me play cuz I do not remember welcome in
back a buck oh sorry one second
I'll be right back. All right, no worries. Thank you for coming and writing. I'll present you
cute little ball of evil and chaos. Oh yes, I love that cute little ball of evil and chaos.
Oh, such a sweet thing.
Oh, does she play a spoopy game again? Play a spoopy game. Oh, I forgot to turn off the
Sorry. Sorry, sorry. We are so scuffed today. We're extremely scuffed.
You don't like it when I make love to your ears? Why not? Isn't that what you're here for?
I'm not sleepy. Stop lying. I have a red ball. I'm not sleepy.
Not sleepy.
Am I a good girl? She comes back. Sure. You didn't know that.
She was guessing characters without her glasses, bro. Want to know something funny?
Want to know something funny? I also wear glasses and all of these streams. I have not been wearing
them. I can't see shit. I can't see shit. It's only words, letters and numbers. If they're
really small, I can't see them. They're really blurry, but it's okay. It's fine. It's not crazy
badly. At least I can see images and stuff. So if you'd probably see my if you see me
going like this, it's probably squinting really hard to see. No, I can't wear contact lenses.
I have very sensitive eyes, unfortunately. Azura is my name. What should we name the
farm? Yeah, glasses mess with it. I wouldn't be able to do this.
If I had them on, so. Azura's dairy farm, Goatland Ranch.
This is one of my favorite games. I haven't been excited for you to play it since I saw your
schedule. I read that it's haven't and I don't know why, but it's like my own brain is trying to
hurt my feelings. Ram Ranch. That's not Ram Ranch. Yes, vote Ram Ranch. Ram Ranch farm.
Ram Ranch farm.
I've been outed. I've been outed. Now everyone knows that I can't see and that's why I keep
misreading stuff. I've been outed. I'm going to run a run a poll. You're on a poll. Yeah.
Yeah, I could do that. What the heck? What the heck? What is that? What is that? Is that me?
Sorry. My voice played back in my own ears. Those girls. It's not horrible. So what do you guys
like? You like that? All right, we start a poll. We have Nama of farm. We have Ram Ranch. We have
Kodah of We have
Aldor
I love you so much.
Dairy goat farm?
Creamy what?
What is this?
What the fuck?
Is it?
There's so many options.
I'm only going to pick the four options.
I have four options.
We have Ram Ranch, Allure, Dairy Dairy Goat's Farm, and Creamy Creamy Crab.
Welcome back.
What a good girl.
She came back.
Are you going to have headphones in your ear listening to my voice as you clean?
I will torment you.
Emmy, hi Emmy.
How are you doing Emmy?
I want speakers even better.
I'm starting the poll.
Get the voting vote for your name on the form.
Vote away.
Emmy is doing some nice, what is this?
Summer cleaning?
Such a good girl cleaning.
Cleaning up her house.
So good.
My chat bros again.
Creamy is winning.
A goat farm would be nice.
I like a goat farm.
Isn't this the new map?
I think Creamy Crab is one.
Goodness.
How do you end poll again?
End poll.
It doesn't even fit.
It's too long.
It doesn't fit.
It's too big.
Too big.
I need to make it fit.
I ran around by default.
No.
Can ran around even fit?
It does.
Creamy ranch?
It smells gross.
You can't go back.
Creamy ranch?
Nope.
Can't fit the H.
Wow.
Who is your favorite memorable character?
Crobus.
Crogobus?
The stinky guy in the sewers.
Little shadow boom.
What are you talking about?
I married him.
In my mind, I married him.
What are these other names?
What folds?
No.
Bad squishy.
Bad.
You're being a stinker.
Bad squishy.
What's the most stressful pull ever?
Oh no.
What's with you guys and Creamy here?
What's with you and Cream?
What's with you guys and Creamy?
What's with you guys and Cream?
farm my favorite thing bread
bread
Hehehe
Bum-ba-dum-bum
Mama bum bum bum
Bum-ba
Your most popular product
DREAMY GOAT FARM
Are ever gonna make a full, long GOAT FARM
hehe
Pls
Yeh
Job desires milk
Hehehe
Let's just start with chicken too, yeah I saw it, I think it's cool, we'll keep the
chickens to have some eggies, we need eggies and we'll get to make money a little faster.
A bread song cover, what's a bread, there's a song called bread, how come I've never heard
of this, what, I want to sing it, song about bread, what, we are winning.
I don't have that squishy, I do not have that, unfortunately, and I like bread,
so I chose bread, bread and milk is good, bread and milk is good, so I chose bread.
Am I doing this right? Is it not orange? Oh, orange.
Hi, it's literally called bread song, I'll look it up and I'll see if I can sing that,
maybe, can I use a slice of the yummy bread, yeah you can have a slice, one slice of my bread,
I got a whole pound bread, can't call it a cake.
The color is ugly, yeah.
I'm cool and hip, like the cool kids, cool and hip, they have different cats now, there's
different cats, there's a white cat, and there's a black one, there's a black cat, I want a
black cat, why a black cat, there's more doggies, there's more doggies, what, that's so cute,
I want a black cat, it has been decided, it's a deciding factor, we begin,
and for a very special granddaughter, me, I want you to have the sealed envelope,
that will come a day, when you feel crushed by the burden of modern life, and your bright
spirit will fade before growing emptiness, when that happens my dear, you'll be ready for this gift.
xx years later, we're gonna have joja, joja, terminate it,
dang, he's dead, where you can't even see that, he's dead, wait, I'm in the way,
I can't do a step body in the corner, I can't do a step body at the desk, you're dead,
there Azura, if you're reading this, you must be in dire need of change, the same thing happened
to me long ago, I'd lost sight of what mattered most in life, real connections with other people
and nature, so I dropped everything and moved to the place I truly beloved, I've enclosed
the key to that place, my pride and joy, creamy goat farm, it's located in startle valley on the
southern coast, it's the perfect place to start your new life, this was most precious gift of all,
and now it's now, and now it's yours, I know you'll honor the family name, my dear, good luck, love
grandpa,
please, every wish is still alive, say hi to the older guy for me, will ya,
eh,
wear some peace, grandpa,
mm,
I saw it ended the pole,
I saw it ended it, it turns out I didn't, oops,
back in my day, an office job was enough to let you move and start a farm, now you need
10 incomes to make rent, facts, absolute facts, facts, I don't know why I read that in old man
voice by the way,
hello, you must be Azura, I'm Robin, the local carpenter,
Merlu has sent me here to fetch you and show you the way to your new home,
he's there right now tidying things up for your revival, the farm's right over there,
if you'll follow me,
this farm is massive,
this is creamy goat farm, creamy goat farm,
what's the matter, sure it's a bit overgrown, but there's some good soil underneath that
mess, with a little dedication you'll have it clean up no time,
and here we are, your new home, my new home,
ah, new farmer,
welcome, I'm newest mayor of Pelican town,
you know, everyone's been asking about you,
it's not every day that someone new moves in, it's quite a big deal,
so you're moving into your grandfather's old cottage,
it's a good house, very rustic,
rustic, that's one way to put it, that's rude, crusty, oh,
I need to disrespect, wow,
I can't, crusty, but feel a little more, very rude,
don't listen to her, as rough, as rough, she's just trying to make you dissatisfied,
so that you buy one of her house of grains,
you're my best,
anyway, you must be tired from the long journey, you should get some rest,
tomorrow you ought to explore the town a bit, and introduce yourself,
the townspeople would appreciate that,
the townspeople, oh, I almost forgot, if you have anything to sell,
just place it in this box here, and come by during the day, oh, this is night,
during the night to collect it, well good luck,
bye, bye,
why was the chicken kuru kuru kuru kuru cut off, it was cut off,
I didn't press anything, it was cut off,
I don't remember how to play,
I was really, really far in my other thingy,
I forgot a lot of stuff,
and I'm a cheater, would you call it cheating, to want perfection,
to use the stardewiki, does anyone else use stardewiki,
is that, is that really cheating,
cheating would be giving yourself money, like in the sems,
he comes by at 3am to carry a box full of sea slugs to sell them,
what, wiki is a must, right, I feel the same way,
I'm gonna play this blind, I leave everything up to you guys,
you guys will guide me to the perfect farm,
perfect farm layout, I'm going in blind, this is the first time I'm going in blind,
there's so many new things I heard,
I'm gonna go in blind,
hey tickeries, hello tickeries, how you doing little tickeries,
I lost,
ah, here we go,
There used to be like so much that you have to do in here, you know, so you gotta use the
wiki.
But you can come up here?
What's this?
What's up here?
Does it matter?
What's this?
Oh!
It's the...
It's the teleporter teleport thingy.
I like the little area, Tim.
It's a really cute little secluded little area.
Is this not a cute little area to put it on?
Looks like a little shrine.
I'm like using Cheering Yard and playing Ray if you don't have a day-to-day buy a buy
hour spreadsheet open.
The only thing I remember is Sherbury's Cell for a Lot are easy to manage, they are.
Tis is true.
Oh yeah, am I out of energy so I'm just gonna go talk to people.
Night squish.
Night night.
Good night.
It's been so long since I played.
It's been a long time for me too.
It's been a really long time.
You can see everything now.
Was this always a thing?
Well, there.
I'm Gus.
Chef and owner of the Star Drop Saloon.
That's how I think his voice sounds like.
Is that weird?
I'm Gus.
Hello.
I think it's the moustache.
It's the moustache to give those vibes.
Why hello?
Welcome to our little community, dear.
You can call me Granny if you like.
Sup Granny?
You doing Granny?
Shoop.
Oh, you aren't exactly how I imagined.
But that's okay.
I'm Jody.
It's a quiet little town.
It's very exciting when someone new moves in.
Having a farm around could really change things.
I don't think I can give a voice to everyone.
I think of a voice for everyone.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
I'm Harvey.
I just figured this is really nerdy.
But very deep, nerdy.
Like, it's a very, it's a very, it's a very, it's a,
I perform regular checkups and medical procedures
for all the residents.
There's too many characters.
Actually.
It's Farmer Azura.
I haven't even introduced myself to you.
How do you know that?
Who told you?
Hey, it's Mrs. Azura, the new farmer.
I'm Pierre, one of the local general store.
If you're looking for seeds.
My shop is a place to go out also buy produce from you.
I'll also buy produce from you.
Pashnips.
We're going to buy some Pashnips.
Wait, I can do this.
Haha.
I'm sorry, I like even numbers.
Mer.
Do you need Pashnips?
Hi, Leia.
Leia's cute.
All these mighties.
God potatoes.
I'm rebelling against the system.
I'm getting Pashnips.
Gotta get those Pashnips.
I like how it cleared out the whole left of the farm.
And now I can't plant these because I can clear out the front.
Oh no, the energy.
What do I do?
Oh, what's that?
What is that?
Is that a sapling?
Oh, cool.
It looked different.
Animals?
Oh, you can see.
Animals on the list.
Glickity.
Glackity.
Oh, starting to get exhausted?
Uh-oh.
I can rest a little bit.
I'll rest.
Can you turn that off?
No, turn that on by itself, right?
No.
Does this...
Does this still work?
Or does it only work in...
No, it only works in, um...
Anna, Anna.
I'm crying.
There's no other way to restore your energy.
Ooh, I can feel it overtaking me.
Will I pass out?
I haven't even finished the day.
I haven't even done anything.
Where's my butt again?
Does this give me energy?
If you eat this?
It doesn't say.
No?
No.
Oh, man.
Hi, it's Alex.
Hi, Alex.
This is the most...
Carefree I've played in this game.
I don't think I can read everything in this game.
Hi, Maru.
It's been there.
I like Panea.
Panea.
Panini.
And Panini.
It's clumped.
Hey, I like his beard.
I have Mustache.
Mustache.
Is it all?
Is there more people?
Can I miss someone?
I'm doing okay.
I'm doing...
great.
Is it Shan?
I don't know you.
That's my purse.
Why are you talking to me?
Disrespectful.
Rude.
Hey, kid.
My name's Pam.
I'm Pamelaum.
I'm Emily.
You can make it.
You can make out your face.
You're going to have to love it here.
Am I?
Yes.
One more time.
Celebrate.
You're going to sweat and dry.
Tonight
Come on, I like to keep the house fun. I
Guess I have to sleep
We sleeping
I
Hang on
Are you guys gonna just let me are you guys gonna just let me let me
Are you guys just gonna let this stream go
Like that. I just checked my microphone. I double checked
Oh my god, it's peeking
Was I not killing anyone's ears?
I can't say anything
It's okay to sound check me. It's okay to sound check me. Oh my god
Oh
My goodness
It's so bad
Every time I restart
Uh opus for some reason
Every time I restart my settings completely restart as well. I have no clue why it does that
It's really dumb really dumb
I
I'm so sorry for anyone who watches this video or bod later
Your poor eardrums are gonna get exploded
I'm so sorry
He
I keep finding cool stuff but my backpack
Is full
Does this sound like you?
Well, the air has gotten you covered
Stop by the air's general store today and check out our affordable size to 24 packs
Oh backpack
See you soon
And while you're at it, why don't you stop by in the description in the video below
And click on the merchandise and buy your merchandise
today
I had a little stretchy
The beginning of that
Little there
little there
Just got back from a fishy trip
You should come down to the beach sometime
I've got something for you
Willy Willy Willy
Willy Willy
I mean I'll see Willy
I
I'm here with the jet doing ad like that
What
Like the best sales pitch
So
Hmm what what what
Oh
No
I don't think so, I don't think so.
She almost caught me, she almost caught me, digging in the trash, she almost caught me.
Hi Haley, you're that no bomber girl, or whatever, aren't you?
I am, huh?
Oh, I mean, if it weren't for those horrendous, rude, you might actually be pretty.
I'm gorgeous, what do you mean?
Actually, never mind.
Wow!
My feelings!
I'm gorgeous!
Oh, hey, Haley.
No time to smile, I want you to wait there miss.
Her there was a newcomer in town, good to finally meet you.
Ah, I'm still trying to unwind from a month out on the salty seas, I cannot read.
It was a big haul, I sold a lot of good fish, yeah, good fish.
Finally saved enough to buy a new ride, ooh, a new ride.
Here, I want you to have my old fishing ride.
It's important to me that the art of old fishing stays alive,
and hey, maybe you'll buy something from the shop once in a while.
I want you, you received a bamboo pole.
There's good water here in the valley, all kinds of fish.
Oh yeah, my shop's back open now, so come by if you need supplies.
I'll also buy anything you catch.
If it smells, it sells.
Hey, that's what my old papper used to say anyways.
Old papper.
I want you to want me.
What is that I want?
Bam!
What is this?
I don't know.
Carrots!
What's this?
Eh, eh.
You found an artifact.
Creator of the local museum, I don't want to know about this.
Carrots!
Uh, uh, yeah!
Hey, Elliot.
Elliot.
I like your hair.
I got some new ideas asleep on.
Bala.
I don't want to get rid of the clay.
Clay is hard to come by.
Well, let's still be there.
Alpels still be there.
I like trash digging.
I have carrots, they added carrots.
That's new.
I didn't have carrots before.
That's a clay.
Oh no.
It's not the way I love your eyes,
but it took me by surprise.
The fun is not so fun.
Not that close.
Can I plant these?
Plant in the spring.
Is this spring?
It is.
It's like magic.
I don't feel like a fun.
I don't feel, I never get...
I don't feel like a...
I really want to do a karaoke stream.
Sounds like fun.
Magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic magic
I'm exhausted already. I was getting into this. It was far man. It was grove man.
Spell you got on me. Sly magic. I'm going to feel like I'm falling in love. I'm going to feel like I'll never get pop on. I'm going to feel like you'll never get pop on.
You can feel like I'll never get pop on.
Why is it only three? Time is going by. I can't. How do you get energy? Does this really not work anymore? It really doesn't work anymore.
Oh man. Introduction. So I need more people. Horace Egg from New York. Chimkyeon. So this is the museum. I forgot to visit the museum.
Hi chickadees. You're not big enough yet for me to take your Iggy's.
Introduction.
Music. The good times.
For the bad times. We're in love. When it's over. When I'm on fire. Have a good night. Have a nice time.
Listen Zoey. Save my world. Save my soul. Save my kind. Save my world. Save my soul. Save my kind.
Hi Sam.
It just turned six o'clock. Come on.
I came all the way over here.
Who else is there to meet? I met everyone here. I'm missing someone.
The bra.
A stranger. My name is Vincent. Mama says not to talk to strangers. You seem okay. I'm perfectly okay.
Mama's not around. This mama could take care of you. Don't worry.
I got a fish. I got a fish.
It actually stops you from fishing. That's funny.
Hi Marne. How are you Marne?
It actually gives you an X on you when you're about to hit the limit. That's crazy. That's new. That's actually new. They never had that either.
They just make you walk really slow all the way back.
I'm in danger. I'm in danger.
I'm in danger.
We're yipping. We're leveling up. Yeah, let's go.
It's raining. I don't have to do the thingy.
It's only nice and beautiful tomorrow.
I don't have to do that.
I'm in danger. I'm in danger.
Good chickens. Good good.
Swag. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance.
I am missing someone. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance.
I know you don't get a chance to take a break this often. I know your life is feeding and it isn't stopping.
You can take my shirt and just go ahead and fight for father.
Swag. Swag. Swag. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance.
Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance. Loses of the dance.
Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come
Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Everybody dance. Ah! A blow!
Oh. Is that it? Can you say anything else?
Did I meet everybody? Was that a book? A book?
Was that a book? Where?
The book where?
Can't tell what I got.
I got this.
A prehistoric Hand X.
Nice answer.
To take.
That's what I picked up.
Don't you just like, just chillin.
Relaxin.
Bye, man.
Bye, bye.
Bye.
I can't play the songs on stream, but I can sing them for you.
That's so much better, right?
Grilled artifact.
Am I missing someone?
What am I missing?
Uh, Abigail.
Oh, alright. I forgot they had a son.
I really had a son.
Oh boy.
Oh, and Linus. Right about Linus.
Who's there?
Absmole.
Not a single person in the entire collection.
Eapsmole.
What's this? You found something? Let me see it.
Remind me of the ball.
It's very old.
It's very old. It's very old.
I love studying it.
Greater detail, but it's yours.
It is yours.
I've got a favor to ask you.
Would you consider donating any new artifacts and minerals that you find?
We could make ground breaking the story together.
Oh, and who knows?
If you keep donating, I might come across some interesting items to send your way.
Think about it, will you?
If you decide to donate, just bring the objects to the front desk.
Okay.
Is there a way to turn down the music?
This is really loud for me.
No matter how much I turn it down, it's so loud.
It's still loud.
Okay, there we go.
It's quiet for me now. It's so loud.
E-Haul, partner.
Acapella is better.
I like my acapella singing.
My horrendous singing.
Thank you.
Sleepy.
In my head.
People watching me.
It's like I'm losing my mind.
Well, since we're out and about, why don't we...
Well, we don't have space.
We don't have any space to fish.
We can all catch a couple of the same fish.
It's like I'm losing my mind.
It's like they're watching me.
Wait, I need to talk to you.
It's like I'm losing my mind.
It's like they're watching me.
You can bet that, never got a sweat that.
Boom.
It's like I'm losing my mind.
My stomach won't stop grumbling.
My stomach is grumbling, really, really hurting.
It's like I'm losing my mind.
Papa.
Emma.
Is that everybody? Then I talked to everybody.
I swear it was everybody.
Oh Linus.
Linus, oh.
No, bad theory.
Okay.
An Abigail.
Linus, Abigail.
Wait.
I'm not even going to be empty?
Oh, I can fish a little bit.
Yeah.
Oh, what's that?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm not going to be empty.
I think it's just a baby.
It's just a baby.
More carrots! Let's go!
Yay!
I like carrots.
Carrots are nice.
This is right here.
It's a nice little spa.
Oh, I was like, where's my pushing room?
Touch.
I remember.
Oh, where do I belong?
Touch.
I'm something poor.
In my life, I'm fine.
I need something more.
In my mind.
Touch.
I remember.
Pictures came like touch.
Painter in my mind.
Tell me what you see.
A tourist and a dream.
Visitor, it seems.
A half-forgotten song.
Where do I belong?
There's no fish in here.
Tell me what you see.
I need something more.
Kiss suddenly alive.
Happiness arrived.
Hunger like a storm.
How do I begin?
A room within a room.
A door behind a door.
Touch where you leave.
I need something more.
Tell me what you see.
Oh, my God!
I got it. I got that.
No! No!
Touch.
Can I do a storm in Prussia from X-Men?
Anime is serious?
I don't know.
Never tried.
But I have to hear her voice again.
I haven't heard her voice in a long time.
It's been a long time since I heard her voice last.
Hold on.
If love is the answer you.
If love is the answer you're home.
Hold on.
Love is the answer you hold hold on
Love is the answer you hold
I got this one
I'm gonna get this one
It's balancing on water
The plant is Jesus
It's Jesus
Uh oh
Oh no
Can I make it back in this maze?
I don't get stuff
Let me out
Freedom
One fish of each, I think
Should be good
Carrots
Can I make a little bit of Buccarones?
Beautiful voice, why do I like you?
Oh, why do I feel like, wow
Wow, I'm fooling myself
Why do I feel like you could do Steven Universe songs really well?
I sung quite a lot of, my favorite song is Steven Universe's
Pearl song
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
One of my favorite ones
Weeping
Unofficial karaoke stream, yeah, super unofficial
Maybe Anya
Pearl song hurts a bit
It hurts, like, emotionally
Emotionally
War and glory, reinvention, fusion, freedom
I have tension out in daylight
My potential, bold, precise, experimental
Who am I now in this world without her?
I'm petty and dull, the nerve to doubt her
What does it matter, it's already done
My wife got to be there for her swan
It's over, isn't it?
I don't know, isn't it over?
I love that song
Dee-dee-dee-dee-dee
Look what you've done, now I have to listen to it
Look what you've done
Shhh
Yeah
Gotta pause the game
I was fine
With the mint
Would come into her life now and again
Oh, I was fine
So I knew
That didn't really matter until you
I was fine
Okay
I felt I was all some silly game
Over her
Would she choose
And now let's see if I'd ever thought I'd lose
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it over you want
And she chose you
And she loved you
And she's gone
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
War and glory
Reinvention, fusion, freedom
Retention, out in daylight
My potential, bold, precise
Experimental
Who am I now in this world without her?
Petty and dull with the nerve without her
What does it matter, it's already done
Now I've got to be there for her son
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it over you want
And she chose you
And she loved you
And she's gone
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
Browl
I love that song
Uh-oh
If I could begin to be
Half of what you think of me
I could do about anything
I could even learn how to love
When I see the way you act
Wondering I'm coming back
I could do about anything
I could even learn how to love
Like you
I always thought I might be bad
But why so glad I've skirted you
I think you're so good
And I'm nothing like you. Look at you go. I just adore you and I wish that I knew
What makes you think I'm so special
If I could begin to do something that does right by you
I could do about anything. I would even learn how to love
When I see the way you look shaken by how long it took
I could do about anything. I could even learn how to love like you
Love like you. Love me like you
Come out of your room. I need to greet you. Come out
I loved SU for a long time. Touched my heart. Touched my heart in ways that not many cartoons do
Yeah
Here comes a thought that does calm the mind
Let me in when she come out her room
You'd be surprised that I can be really loud when singing
Kind of creepy as hell
I can sing really really loudly but given the fact that I do live with my family
I'm actually singing really quietly
I can't sing any louder
I can get really really really loud
Super super duper duper loud
Yeah, I felt a tiny bit rushed but even though it felt a little rushed
It was still okay. I think it was really good
But is it only her? Does she come out?
Is she still in her room?
I'm only waiting for her to come out
What the f- Where'd she go? Where is she? Where'd she go?
What the f- Where is she?
What the f- Where? What?
What the f- This bitch! Where'd she go?
It's empty
How she just live? I don't understand
I was waiting for her
What the f-
She avoiding me. She didn't like me
Oh wow, it disappeared
Give me the fish
Give me that fish
What if it was you hanging up on this wall?
If it was you, I'd say how much you would be laughing at all
Don't know why that- I don't know
I haven't heard that- I haven't heard a jingle from that commercial in so long
Nor have I heard the song anywhere
I don't know why it decided to enter my brain just now, but it did
What the f-
What, even just singing a song can look a bad?
Oh someone sent me, thank you so much
For the $5 tip
All for fun
Tip for our enchanting song-tris
Thank you, thank you for the tip
I didn't hear it
I didn't hear it go off at all, actually
Try because I muted this
Try because I muted this because the game is so loud for me
I turned this down
Remova
Remova's here
Remova can't move it there
I broke it
I broke it, let's just pretend I didn't touch nothing, I didn't touch anything
Yeah, I mean I like us you ending for what it is
But after hearing all the behind the scenes drama, it could have been so much more
It could have, it's so true
So much happened
Dang, my whole playlist is now
S.U. songs
And Disney songs
There's just a bunch of Disney songs
You do it for him
And you do it again
You do it for her
That is to say
About the future, I ain't back to where your damn is
Fucking with that passion baby
I'm worried about the future
Future, future, future, future, future
Future, future, future, future
Oh you know what I forgot about?
Birthdays
I ain't no good about that, I'm gone
I ain't make a dollars, at least I'm making sense
But I buy a dollar, money, give me money?
Oh, you started?
I do it
Ain't no sucker baby
And inspect it
I'm worried about the future
I think I broke, hang on
Give me one second
It broke
I
Can't got no time to waste on bullshit
Uh oh
Second place
Oh
I do it
You saw nothing
The farm is going pretty good
We're all relaxed and chillin
Have a good time
Is any birthdays coming up?
On the 7th
On my house
I can go say hi to Linus actually
Let's go say hi to Linus
I
I keep wasting my energy because I keep clicking back
on that
I